[Applause]
from my first days in office
my Administration has led with a bold
agenda to address the climate crisis and
increase energy security at home and
around the world
we immediately rejoined the Paris
agreement
we convened major climate Summits and
re-established
I apologize you ever pulled out of the
agreement
we established major economic and major
economies Forum to Spur countries around
the world to raise raise their climate
ambitions
last year cop 26 in Glasgow the United
States helped deliver critical
commitments that will get two-thirds of
the world's GDP on track to limit
warming to 1.5 degrees Celsius
over the past two years the United
States has delivered unprecedented
progress at home
through a generational investment and
upgrading our nation's infrastructure
we're making up our power grid better
able to transmit clean energy expanding
public traffic Transit and rail
building Nationwide network of electric
vehicle charging stations over 50 000.
and this summer the United States
Congress passed and I signed the law my
proposal for the biggest most important
climate bill in the history of our
country
the inflation reduction Act
it includes lesson I asked for but a
significant amount
368 billion dollars
to support
clean electric clean electric
electricity everything from onshore
offshore wind to distributed solar zero
emissions vehicles and sustainable
Aviation fuels more efficient
electrified buildings cleaner industrial
processes and Manufacturing
climate smart Agriculture and Forestry
and more
look our department of energy estimates
that the new law will reduce emissions
in the United States by about 1 billion
tons in 2030.